Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a
long time, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link,
this week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're ringing in the new year, happy 2021.
We're not recording this in 2021,
you know, just full transparency.
We can still celebrate it.
I still believe that it's a happy 2021.
Yeah, we're gonna make it in 2021.
And for you, listener,
you're certainly in 2021 or later,
it could be years later.
Like an archive?
Yeah, it's nice to know that
this is as permanent as.
Are you saying you think this
is gonna be the Smithsonian?
No, I was not.
That's a little pompous of you.
I agree, 'cause that's
not what I was saying.
What does that even really
mean anymore, though,
to be the Smithsonian?
And that's what we're tackling today,
new year, new issues.
What does that really mean
to be the Smithsonian Institution Museum.
Who cares about the Smithsonian?
I like the Smithsonian,
shout out to all of the Mythical Beasts
who work at the Smithsonian
or the National Archive,
and all that type of stuff.
Yeah, right.
But today we gotta tell you
about our expedition with our boys.
Yeah, the camping trip.
When we went
to Death Valley.
I, as you might have remembered,
in my top 10 moments of the year,
I don't remember what number
it was, but it was up there,
it was in the top 10 of my
favorite things that happened,
was our trip that we took with the boys.
Me and my boys.
I think it was number four.
Maybe, me and my boys, Locke and Shepherd,
you and your boys, what are their names,
Lincoln and Lando.
I think their names are Lincoln and Lando.
And to Death Valley.
And so we said we would
not talk about it at all
on that podcast
because a number of stories were generated
during our short trip,
that we will now share.
I'm so glad that we did it,
I gotta say it was my idea,
I don't know if that's
true but I'm gonna say it,
it was my idea.
I was like, let's take the
boys on a camping trip.
I don't recall, so I'll give you credit.
I was definitely looking
for another opportunity
to rent a Sprinter van
and dabble, once again, in that #vanlife.
So, that's been on my mind a lot
and Christy and I went, highlight of 2020.
But yeah, I wanted to
give it a kid mode test.
And I'd only used my, I call it my rig,
is that what you would call my FJ Cruiser?
Sure.
My FJ Cruiser, which I recently invested
in some work being done on it.
I got the rooftop tent,
that was all for my solo trip.
But the thing that I
learned on my solo trip
is that I needed a more
efficient way to store things,
especially if I was gonna
take any other beings with me
on a camping trip.
And I don't know if you noticed
how proud I was of my drawer.
I did notice how proud
you were of your drawer.
Yeah, I got a drawer
and you might think, what do
you mean you got a drawer?
I got a drawer, a metal drawer, that,
if you look at an SUV, the back of an SUV,
you've got the part behind the back seats,
what would you call that?
The boot is what Christy
and her family call it,
but I always called the boot
the thing where your boots would go,
where your feet go in
the front of the car,
but I think I'm wrong, actually.
That doesn't make any sense.
They call a trunk a boot.
Well, it's not a trunk
because it's just the back of an SUV.
The back end.
There's a drawer that has been made,
a metal drawer, to fit the entire thing.
And so, basically, it raises
the level of the floor up,
so you still have all that space,
but then there's a foot deep drawer
that covers that whole thing.
It's not cheap.
Are you prepared to say how much you paid
for one drawer to go in
the back of your truck?
No, I'm not.
It's a very expensive drawer.
Less than $1,000.
Oh, okay.
I actually thought it
was more than $1,000.
No.
So, and by the way, I'm
sniffing 'cause of an allergy,
I waited too long to take my pill today.
I hate when I bring
allergies to "Ear Biscuits",
but, every once in a while, I do.
So anyway.
If it makes your eyes water
it can look like you're getting emotional.
This drawer, I was excited
about time with my sons,
but I was most excited about the drawer.
But pulling it out?
Over and over again.
Then pushing it back in.
So smooth.
But it's funny how just one
drawer, properly spaced,
can change everything.
Really, though?
Really?
You didn't see how inefficiently
I had packed everything
on my solo trip,
because I didn't have to
worry about it too much.
'Cause you gotta unpack the stuff
to get to the stuff behind the stuff
and you have to repack it to move.
Is your drawer, even
right now at this moment,
still full of stuff?
I could go camping tonight.
You could bug out, you
have a bug out vehicle now.
I have everything except food.
Okay.
Food and water, but equipment
and lights.
It's stored there permanent?
Ways to start fire and
tools, and all that stuff,
all the camping stuff, the
cooking stuff, it's all in there.
See, if I owned a van.
You'd be ready to go.
I'd have one of those too
and I'd also have a shower,
a toilet, a sink, a burner,
and a bed inside of a vehicle.
But would you have a drawer?
I'd have a lot of drawers.
No drawer's as big as my drawer.
No big-ass back metal drawer, no.
A lot of little drawers,
I don't think a lot of little drawers
can add up to one big drawer.
I don't know how drawer math works, but.
No, the van was incredible, I will say,
I was envious of the van.
I rented a different van.
It was very big.
From a different set of people.
It was very tall, too
tall for a drive-through.
Yeah.
You can't get drive-through
food in this van.
Could you stand up inside of the van?
I really didn't invite you in.
Do you know the only
time I got into your van,
the entire time?
There's one specific time,
do you remember this?
When you did number two in my van?
No, I did not,
I was not one of the people
who did number two in that van.
You could tell that I wasn't
really chomping at the bit
for you to do number two in my van.
I didn't do number two in your van.
The one time I got in your van,
it was on the way to Death Valley,
when we stopped at that gas station
in the middle of nowhere,
basically, it's one of
the only things on 395,
you're going up towards Mammoth,
and it was that gas
station that had the Subway
and we ended up eating at Subway,
and it was the first time we
had eaten at Subway in a while.
Yeah.
And we were sitting there
in the parking lot, eating.
Shout out to the Mythical Beast
who worked at that Subway.
Oh yeah, yeah.
And then he came outside
and got a picture with us.
Yeah, he did.
We didn't take our masks off.
No we didn't.
Try'na be a good example.
A woman came up
and started asking
questions about your van.
That's right.
And she was like,
can you stand up in there?
And I was like, well, let me see.
Oh, you literally never went in there.
Never, other than that one moment.
I kind of feel bad that
you never went in the van.
I didn't have a need to,
You didn't have a need to.
While it's very big,
in some senses, it's really like, well,
there's the bed in the back
taking up most of the room
and then there's the
bathroom and the sink,
and then there's seats,
and I wasn't riding in it,
I was driving my own car,
so I didn't feel left out.
And, to answer your question,
as a six foot seven man
with shoes on,
meaning a man who was six
foot seven with shoes on
'cause I'm six six and a half.
Oh.
I could not stand up exactly
straight in your van,
I had to hunch a little bit,
which is not a problem
for me, I'm used to it,
a lifetime of hunching
has made me used to it.
So I think it's probably
six foot five, six foot six clearance.
This is a different van
than the one I got before,
but it's basically the same model,
it was one year newer.
It's a 2021.
Mercedes.
Yeah, for real, it was
like fresh off the lot
kind of a thing,
the couple gave me a thorough tour,
but I was like I've already done this,
I've been to Utah.
Because you rented it from an individual,
a couple, a private person.
Private people put their vans on,
there's a website called Outdoorsy.
There's probably others too,
but, anyway, they gave me the tour
and, yeah,
I got the impression that they
probably had rented it out
just a couple of times.
It was very new and very fresh for them.
Yeah, it was a very nice van.
Very detailed tour, a little too detailed,
I mean, a 45 minute tour
of a van, but I get it.
Big van.
You've got
this really expensive van,
you're letting some stranger use it,
you're charging 'em and they got insurance
and all this stuff that
you have to get for it,
but, still, it might be
a little nerve wracking
to rent out your Mercedes baby.
But, anyway, we went to Death Valley
'cause, at that time of year,
it broke the record for
the hottest place where?
Not on earth, on earth?
It might be the hottest
place on earth this year,
it was 131 or maybe 134
degrees, I don't know.
Fahrenheit.
Yeah, thank goodness.
Yeah, but when we went.
Mid 70s during the day.
The weekend before Thanksgiving, yeah.
Perfect weather.
Perfect time to be there.
And, let's see, so what's the first story?
We drive in and we're
taking some good photos,
taking some group photos,
I've got one photo of the boys
and it looks like a band photo.
We've got some really, really good photos
that we'll give to Kiko.
For the video version of this.
Because there's some, that's right,
there's a video version
of this on YouTube,
if you happen to be listening.
And really great photos,
I took some 360 photos.
I haven't seen those yet.
Well, I think I took it of
the first night's campsite
and I did not take any more,
which you will learn
why I didn't take any of the second
and third night's campsites.
And I got some drone footage.
Oh snap.
I got some drone footage
of you driving through that canyon,
through Titus Canyon.
Oh, is it nice?
Haven't looked at it yet.
Okay.
I'm sure it's nice, nice enough.
We get there,
this time of year and
especially in that valley,
the sunset's quick,
it's like 4.30 and the sun
goes over the mountain ridge
and it gets really dark really quick.
Yeah.
But we had
kind of beat the sunset
to get to the first
thing we wanted to see,
which was some sand dunes in the middle.
It's just like sand dunes,
I don't know how else to describe it,
there's a really tall sand
dune at the northern end,
but we're right in the middle,
coming in through Stovepipe Wells.
Yeah, these are the sand
dunes that are easy to get to
and it shows, there was a lot
of people on these sand dunes.
So it's like you're in
the middle of the desert
and in this giant valley,
and we're talking sand dunes
that are 150/200 feet high,
maybe some of the biggest ones.
There's definitely bigger in other places.
The Eureka Dunes are like 700 feet tall,
is what I've heard.
Crazy.
Can you imagine that?
'Cause these are giant
and it really is that kind of thing
that I've only seen in movies
where somebody'll be in the Sahara
and it's just like they're
walking up the ridge
of one of those giant sand
dunes, through the desert.
Yeah.
Well, there's that, that exists here.
And the boys loved it,
that was a really good
call to go there first
because we were walking
out on these sand dunes
and it's really exhausting
walking up these sand dunes,
but everybody had a ball
and, you know, you really don't know.
I feel like it was my mission
for my kids to have a good experience.
I'm building a case for van life,
or at least being an outdoorsy person.
And I will say that both of our teenagers
expressed some teenage-ness
about going, before the trip.
Before the trip.
Thinking that, going to the desert,
I don't really understand
why you want me to do this
and is it really gonna be fun?
But you know what, to their credit,
they brought positive attitude.
They had a great attitude
right from the beginning.
And then when we got on those dunes,
before we know it, Shepherd,
we get to the highest dune
that we, realistically,
could walk to and walk up,
which was one of the highest
ones in that set of dunes
and before I know it, I look over there
and Shepherd is halfway down
the dune doing a log roll
and just plumes of dust, just coming up.
I knew this was going to happen
because I know Shepherd,
what I didn't know was
that it would inspire Lando
to, ultimately, try the same thing.
He's not a roll down first,
figure out if it's good idea,
second, kind of a person.
Right.
And, I guess, he observed Shepherd.
But, you know, it warms
your heart as a dad
seeing your kids barrel rolling
and all four of them were doing it
down this sandy slope.
But not the dads.
Not the dads.
Not the two dads.
I'm thinking about my shoulders,
this broad shouldered man
could just crumple up in an instant.
I just took photos and videos,
I was a cinematographer,
I was not a roller.
It was a cool start
and then once we were alarmed
with how quickly it was
getting really dark,
we found the first place that felt,
it felt like it could
be, almost, off-road,
you need a high clearance vehicle
to get to a place where
it would feel isolated
and we could find a campsite,
actually, not a campsite, but just a spot.
Dispersed camping.
Dispersed camping,
once you get out a mile
off the main roads,
you're allowed to camp anywhere you want
in designated swathes of land.
And there's a beauty to the desert,
there's a mindset to appreciating it
but, as we were driving out there,
and I had the youngest
boys in the van with me,
and I'm just like
this is what this van
was made to do, boys.
We're rollicking over some rocks
and going through these washes
with sheer walls on either side.
There was some slight canyons.
Yeah, and we were going through that.
And I was like, when I think
about what I wanted this
trip to be, this is it,
we're gonna find a good spot.
Death Valley,
which now me and you
have been to three times,
Death Valley has it all.
Well it doesn't have trees,
it doesn't have water,
it doesn't have shade.
It has everything that you
would expect in Death Valley
but, just so you understand
if you've never been to
Death Valley National Park,
if you are just picturing
a giant empty desert,
well, yes, that is part of it,
but, along the sides of the desert,
there are so many different
geological formations
and canyons,
the kids were immediately into
how cool the geography was,
right.
Yeah, it's otherworldly.
When you're driving
through this canyon.
It feels like something
off of a movie set,
you're on a foreign world.
And if you just have a regular old car,
a Sedan or whatever, you can
experience a lot of this.
But if you really wanna get
away from the touristy spots,
you need a vehicle that can get there.
Now, we had been a couple of times before,
and, actually, we chronicled
at least one of those trips
with our friend Nick
and the other people that
he does overlanding with
and off-roading with.
Yes, when we took the
showers naked in the.
Hot springs.
Hot springs, yeah.
So, yeah,
we've done the extreme,
technical off-roading thing
in the FJ, you and I both in that.
With the van and the kids
and not a lot of confidence
to be able to fix a problem
in isolated locations,
like any mechanical or technical issues.
I don't even like to think
about something going wrong
because I just wanna be in a place
where, if something goes wrong,
I can just say it's not up to us.
Yeah.
And the van and the rental agreement
would certainly not allow
us to do what we did before.
And you wanna minimize,
you're managing the expectations
of children and teenagers.
And they don't like to
just stay in the car.
You don't wanna be in the car too much.
They wanna get out and do stuff,
but I will say
just because you don't like to think
about something going really wrong,
doesn't mean it won't, because it did.
Yes.
And we'll talk about that.
We'll get into that and more in a second,
but first, listen, we've got
the all new Good Mythical mugs,
fresh for season 19 of GMM.
You might say,
you might even call
this an old school mug,
black mug, nice GMM,
but then you're like, nope, nope, nope,
on the other side, you've got
the "Good Mythical Morning"
with Rhett and Link logo,
so you've got double the logos.
But there's more.
And a retro styling.
But there's more, I can't
currently reach it, so.
Let me do the honors.
When you fill this thing
up with hot liquids,
all of a sudden.
It springs to life like
the desert at night.
You get the cockatrice in the night sky
blowing a fiery "Good Mythical
Morning" with Rhett and Link,
basically inspired by.
The intro.
The new intro.
Yeah, so the whole
thing with heated liquid
reveals a night sky
and a cockatrice blowing the flame.
And then when it cools down.
It goes away again.
It goes away and it's black again.
Color changing, scene
inducing, heat activated mugs,
we keep upping the ante,
that's what we keep doing.
What's next?
I don't know, a conscious cup.
There it is.
Sounds like something
that's made out of recycled materials.
No, this is a cup that thinks for you.
Yeah, that's 2022.
I've been letting my cups
think for me for years,
it just hadn't amounted to
much, see where that's left me.
Mythical.com.
Whoa.
Wow, 2021, man,
we are in sync.
We are in sync, yeah.
So that first night,
the older boys had to camp in a tent
and then me and Lando were
gonna sleep in the van,
and then you and Shepherd were gonna sleep
on top of the FJ in that
fancy rooftop setting.
And you might ask yourself,
well, why'd you make the
older boys sleep in a tent?
Well, technically the
rooftop tent that I got
is a three man tent,
but if you are a experienced camper,
you know that three
person means two person.
It does, doesn't it?
A three person tent is
comfortable for two people.
Don't fall for it.
And when one of the persons
is as big as my person,
even if the other person is
as small as Shepherd's person,
Shepherd and I were basically
right next to each other,
could not have comfortably
gotten another being
in there with us, anyway.
And you technically could've
gotten somebody into the van,
but it would've required
moving a bunch of stuff out.
Yeah, it would be underneath the bed
and a bunk bed situation.
And we also thought this
was a good opportunity
for our teenage sons
to learn how to set a fricking
tent up and break it down.
You know, what they did it.
They did.
I gotta give 'em credit,
man, just positive attitudes.
If it was just me and my kids,
it would have been a lot more challenging.
Yeah.
And I have to think the
same, the other way, right,
so it was nice that they had compadres.
You're less likely to say
and do embarrassing things
and lose your cool,
both ways, both the kids and the parents,
when you are co-mingled.
The thing that I learned the first night,
it hit me like a ton of
bricks and we talked about it,
is that my previous camping
experience with Christy,
the first time we had ever
gone on a camping excursion
just the two of us and,
of course, you were alone,
both of those, which are
different than each other,
are still starkly different
than going camping with multiple children.
Because the amount of time
devoted to getting everything right,
that includes getting
everything right for them,
we barely had time to sit down.
We were scrambling to make dinner
and you got me over here cooking burgers,
while you're cooking mac
and cheese and other stuff
on your setup.
And cooking is a relative term.
Yeah, I kinda got steaks
and burgers confused,
and I got in my mind that
if I overcook the burgers,
it's kinda like a steak,
if you overcook the steak,
they're gonna complain,
you don't want it well done.
But you do want ground beef.
Yeah.
Unless it's been pasteurized.
It was kinda dark, but
everyone did seem to notice
that the burgers weren't
cooked all the way through.
It was more of seared tartare.
Oh gosh.
Which I didn't mind.
I couldn't finish it, Lando was horrified.
So I was like, okay,
but, you know what, I
played to my strengths
and when we were done eating,
I said I'll focus on doing
some dishes and cleaning up,
and I'm back in my zone,
in the cleaning zone.
There was a lot of cleaning going on.
You were cleaning too.
Of course it's been dark for hours,
after we're done eating
and the older boys said,
we're just gonna go off
and explore,
I thought that was a good idea.
So Locke and Lincoln went off,
they just walked down the way that we came
and there is nothing,
no other civilization
or no other sign of human
activity within sight.
Really activity of any kind.
Of any kind.
There are some plants, not many, but some.
And so they walk off and
then I'm doing the dishes,
and I'm trying to remember what happened
if you told me, yeah.
I knew as soon as they
left what my my plan was.
So I come out from finishing the dishes
and the younger boys
were sitting by the fire,
and, of course, they've got screens out
I'm like, boys, put your screens away.
And I was like, I'm gonna
hang out with you guys
because you said.
I'm gonna go scare Locke and Lincoln.
I'm gonna carry on the
McLaughlin tradition
of trying to give your fellow
campers a heart attack.
Shepherd and Lando's eyes
got as big as saucers
and you walked off into the darkness.
And then I'm left,
maybe I'll tell my
perspective of this story
and then you can tell yours.
So I'm sitting there at the campfire
talking to Shepherd and Lando,
and I ended up talking about,
I don't know how we got on it,
but I started talking to them about,
I think it's 'cause you're out camping
and there's a spirit of
independence to camping.
And I started talking about our friend Ben
and his adventurous spirit,
and the things that he
would do in the woods
and out in nature,
and how he fostered, the stuff
that we've shared with you
last year on the podcast.
I was just kinda telling them stories
of all the things that he would do
and inspire us to do, out
in the woods and on canoes,
and how his parents,
when they were not much older than him,
would take him and his canoe
and drive to Lillington
and just drop him off.
Not much older than Shepherd
and Lando, at the time.
Yeah.
You said not much older than him,
like his parents weren't
that much older than him.
No, I said not much older than them.
Yeah.
Lando and Shepherd.
So I was like, can you imagine me and mom
driving you guys, with a
canoe, to the next town over
and then you're just gonna
canoe down the river,
and then half a day later,
we're gonna pick you back up.
And they're super into it,
and I'm like, yeah, this is
what camping's all about,
you got a fire,
you got these kids who are
just expanding their horizons
and forgetting about their screens.
And then, all of a sudden,
I just heard this blood curdling scream
and kerfuffle in the way distance,
and I'm like, Shepherd, that's your dad,
I think he found the older boys.
And then we just waited
for you to come back
and hear the story of what had happened.
Well, I think I've
talked about this before,
I have a thing for scaring people,
it's one of my favorite things
and I've done it all my life,
and it's a family tradition,
my dad did it to me.
And so as soon as they left and
they had their headlamps on,
and we're kind of in this wash,
so it's, essentially, sort
of like a shallow canyon,
they can go this way or
they can go that way,
there's not that many places they can go
and you can see where they're
at because it's so dark.
And so I could see that they
were a long distance away,
'cause I could see their
lights, 'cause it's so flat.
And there was a little bit of moonlight,
there was enough moonlight
for me to walk out there without a light
and my eyes adjusted to the desert,
so I could kind of see where I was going
without being in too much danger.
So I was like, okay, I'm
gonna walk down towards them,
I could see them in the distance,
oh, they've turned back around
and now they're walking
back towards the camp site,
but they're still
many, many hundreds of yards
away from the campsite.
So I'm like, all right,
what am I gonna do?
I'm gonna get on the side of this path,
behind this bush, and
wait for them to come by
and scare the crap out of them.
But then I was like, man,
the desert plants are so sparse and small,
and I'm like, if they're
shining their headlamp
and they see me
behind this very sparse
cactus bush kind of thing,
the whole thing is ruined.
So I was like, I'm gonna
move further off of the road,
get down on my belly behind
this little embankment,
and let them pass and
then come up behind them.
Because not only is that,
you know, they can't see me,
but it will scare them so much
to have something come from behind.
The unknown.
The unknown that they've just
been in versus the campsite,
it makes sense that somebody
we know might be on that side.
So they come, they're walking,
they walk by me and then.
Didn't you hear Locke say something?
Well, here's the deal,
I had to stand up and start
walking towards the road
and as I stood up.
After they passed?
After they passed,
as I stood up and started
taking a couple of steps,
they heard something
and then later we find out
Locke was like, Lincoln,
do you hear something?
And he was like, no.
So Locke is paranoid.
Locke was already scared,
he'd been scared the whole time.
He's kind of skittish in general.
Yeah,
he's scared of the dark.
He's like me.
And so.
He's looking over his
shoulder, not seeing anything.
And then I stop,
but then I walk out
into the middle of this,
basically, this dirt road
that they're walking down.
And then I start taking
more and more steps
and then right before
I really start running,
where they're gonna know,
I probably get 10 feet behind them
and I was like, I'm
gonna let out the lowest,
most guttural sound that I can make
that will sound as unhuman as possible.
And I was just like.
Okay.
And Locke screamed,
I don't think Lincoln screamed,
I didn't hear him scream,
I heard Locke scream.
When they tell this story,
what did they say that they each thought?
Locke thought it might Bigfoot,
which is what I was hoping
and Lincoln said
that his brain was saying
he was super scared,
but he was thinking if that's not Rhett,
I don't know what we're gonna do.
Yeah, yeah,
he's more of a strategic thinker than me,
he knows how to play chess.
Right.
Yeah, so I was encouraged
that he didn't lose his cool completely,
but I know he was scared
because when they came back up
and the three of you walked back,
they just had this sweaty,
exasperated, wide-eyed,
heart rate still pumping kind of vibe
and I could tell that Lincoln
was legitimately scared,
along with Locke, which was obvious.
Listen, it's scary,
it's not as scary as it was
when I was out there by myself
like I told you on the solo trip,
but being out there when there's
just no point of reference,
there's no other people,
you just feel exposed
and you don't know what
mysteries lie in the dark.
I think one of my favorite
things was what happened next
in that you came back
and you told that story,
all three of you told the
story from your perspectives
and then we went on, all of
us, sitting around the fire,
you and I started telling stories,
kind of building on what I was doing
with the stories that I
was already telling them.
Just telling the story
about how we would go camping
across the Cape Fear River
and the one time
that you invested over
an hour of disappearing
from me and the rest of the
friends that we brought camping,
and fully committing to long-term
scaring the crap out of us
by laying in the water
like Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Only my eyes and nose
were above the surface,
like a gator
for a long time.
You know, telling 'em that story,
it was just cool to see our boys
so into us telling the stories
and I think we ended up
telling a few stories
that we had written about in
the "Book of Mythicality",
and I just realized, you know what,
you can't just write stories in a book
and expect your kids to read 'em.
These stories were still new to them.
Like the story of my brother's
which, in the "Book of Mythicality",
it's like a comic strip,
so I don't know how well it's conveyed,
but it's the story of my brother
in his middle school science fair project
which he called "Birds",
which did not have a hypothesis
or any sort of experiment.
It just had a bunch of dismembered birds.
I think it was one bird that he had shot
and then taken apart, and
put on his poster board.
And, to just show you the
body parts of the birds,
it definitely seems like the kind of thing
a serial killer would do
as a middle school science fair project,
but my brother is not a serial killer.
And they all knew him.
It was a different time.
Even my kids know Cole,
so they got a kick out of that
story, all of those stories.
Lando in particular,
that was the conversation
in which I saw Lando
check out a little bit.
Yeah, he's younger, he's
such a sensitive soul
and it turns out he loves birds.
When you're adjusting to camping,
there were a number of moments
when I had to pull him to the side
and say, hey, we're
still having a good time.
He had a number of moments
where he bounced back.
He did well.
And he was good,
and it was helpful that we
had the security of the van,
where we could get snuggled in our blanket
and feel more secure.
Yeah.
So the next morning, we had
to drive out of the campsite
back to the main area to go and explore,
and find our next campsite.
And Locke,
a lot of the kids these
days and kids in California,
I think, especially,
are on a slightly different schedule
when it comes to getting their
driver's permit and license.
Me and you, as soon as we turned 15,
we got our driver's permit,
as soon as we turned 16,
that day I got my license.
Things move a little bit slower
and, obviously, the pandemic
has had an effect on this.
So Locke basically just
got his driver's permit
right before we left
and he's not really driven a car,
we haven't really done the thing
where you just let your
kid drive when they're 14,
like, oh I'll let you drive
around the neighborhood,
or something like that,
we just haven't done that,
don't really have that
kind of neighborhood.
I'm gonna sneeze.
Do it in your sleeve.
Okay, I'm not gonna sneeze,
apparently, it went away.
So he just got his permit,
so I'm like, this is
the perfect opportunity
for him to drive,
you're in the desert,
you're on a dirt road,
there's not any other traffic.
I mean, in the vlog
where we went off-roading with Shepherd,
you let him drive.
Right.
But he was in your lap.
I was in the driver's seat still.
This is for real.
This is giving them 100%
control of the vehicle.
But yeah, we're out there
in the middle of nowhere
and it's just dirt roads leading
back up to the main road.
In fact, you told me
you were gonna do that
and I'm like, well, I'm
gonna go ahead far enough
so that he won't be driving in my dust,
so I go far ahead
and I do not witness anything
that is about to happen.
Okay, so this is a single lane dirt road,
they come through there on a regular basis
with some sort of.
Scraper.
Scraper that pushes the dirt to the side,
almost like snowbanks, right?
So there's no shoulder.
They're dirt banks
and there's big rocks in these dirt banks.
And one of the things that
happens when you start driving
is you don't know where
your car is at on the road,
you're on the left side
and you feel like you're in the middle,
but no, you have a whole
piece of car to your right.
So a lot of new drivers
will be hanging out to the
right a little too much,
I remember doing it as a new driver
and Locke was doing
that almost immediately.
So there's some big
rocks in this embankment,
I'm like, Locke, you're
too far to the right,
you're too far to the right,
come back to the left,
he's like, I don't think I am,
I'm like, listen.
And I actually said something like,
all right, the only way
that this is going to work
is if you assume that when
we are in the car together
and we have a different view of driving,
I will always be right, okay?
During this stage of the relationship,
that doesn't mean forever,
but while you're the
pupil and I'm the teacher,
the only way we can do this is just assume
that I, in my driving experience,
know what I'm talking about, right.
And he, actually, was like,
okay, that makes sense,
so I was like,
and here's how you can tell
where you're at on the road.
Anyway, so we're going
along, he's doing great,
he's doing fine,
I'm having to correct him a little bit
and get him to move to the center,
but I'm trying to be calm.
And then, all of a sudden,
I see another vehicle coming towards us
because, again, this is a single lane,
we're gonna have to move to the
side to let each other pass.
I see that the guy has
stopped and moved to the side,
to let us go,
he's in a Subaru of some kind,
not really super off-road
but enough to be out on this dirt road.
Okay.
But Locke has seen the car
and he has come to a stop,
so that guy thinks that he's
saying that he should go.
Yeah.
But by the time I say,
"Oh he's letting you go",
Locke starts to go and
so does the other guy.
It's like what you would typically do
on foot with someone.
Yeah, you're walking
down the sidewalk.
We're both going right,
we're both going left,
and we're doing a dance.
You're playing Chicken at this point.
What ends up happening
is there's a little
bit of yelling from me.
Saying something like,
just go, no stop, he wants you!
I'm basically embodying
the process, vocally,
I wasn't helping, I'm
sure I wasn't helping.
And Lincoln's in the
back seat just kind of.
Smiling a little bit.
Smiling.
So we get to the point where it looks like
we're both just gonna
drive past each other
with one wheel up on this
dirt embankment on the side.
You both stopped and started
how many times at this point?
Four to five.
That's awkward, man.
That's okay,
it's okay to have one
tire up on this embankment
when you're in an FJ Cruiser, right.
Even though Locke was
getting so far to the right
that I thought he was
gonna get high centered
or whatever,
when, basically, you get stuck
and both wheels, you know.
And so I was like, stay left,
you're getting too far to the right!
You know, slightly calmer than that.
The other guy is doing the same thing
and we eventually get past him,
and then Locke gets back
in the middle and goes,
and then I turn around and look,
and I'm like, I think that guy got stuck.
He's not in a off-road vehicle
and he doesn't seem to be going anywhere.
And so I was like,
Locke, I think that guy got stuck, stop.
So Locke stops, I said "Get out."
I get in the driver's
seat, I put it in reverse
and I back all the way up to this guy.
And, sure enough, he's stuck,
but not only is he stuck,
but three additional vehicles in a row,
three guys who are on an off-road trip
have come out of the mountain.
Same place you came from.
Yeah, are now stopped and
they're out talking to this guy.
And then within the time
that I get out of my car,
they start pushing him off
and they get him off of the
embankment, and they help him.
I get out of the car.
I'm sure that guy said some nice things
about your vehicle.
When I walked up to him, I was like,
hey man, hey listen,
even though Locke is 16,
I was like, hey, I got a
15 year old new driver,
he's driving for the first
time, sorry about that
and he's like, ah, no
problem, they got me,
it's great, it's fine, whatever.
So then I get back in the
car, I drive a little bit,
I'm like, well, we still
have a lot of dirt road to go
and I stop and I was like,
listen, okay, let's start over.
That was something you
couldn't anticipate.
It was probably your fault.
And that was a difficult thing to navigate
in your first driving experience,
and I don't want you to be nervous
and have a bad taste in your mouth
on your first driving experience.
So listen,
let's stop.
Let me give you
another bad experience.
Let's recenter,
I'm gonna calm down a little
bit, you calm down a little bit
because we were both
yelling at each other,
we have very similar
personalities, and let's switch.
So we switch, Locke gets
in the driver's seat,
I get in the passenger seat,
and the three guys who
have helped the Subaru
have come up behind us and
stopped right behind us,
so the lead car is right behind us.
So Locke puts it into
gear, presses the gas,
problem is the gear that
he chose was reverse.
How much gas did he press?
Enough, enough for me to yell again.
I'm telling you, man,
anticipating going forward and
finding yourself in reverse.
And knowing there's the
guy right behind us,
I was like, Locke, Locke, Locke!
I think I just said his name three times.
And he ended up, I don't know
if he just hit the brakes
or he just moved it back into park,
either way, there was a grinding noise.
Oh.
From our car.
We did not ram,
how awful would it have been?
How close did you get,
you didn't hit him?
Several feet, which is
close in a car, right.
And how awful would it have been for his,
again, his first driving experience,
to be running this guy off the road
and then backing into
a guy who helped him.
But after that.
So at that point, what did you do?
He said, "Dad, I don't
wanna drive anymore."
I'm sorry, I got a 13
year old driver here,
he's getting younger with every mistake.
And I felt for him
because what I thought was gonna happen
was the same thing that
happened as we drove in,
which was no other cars,
but on the way out
we have to run against
this person coming at us
and we've got three guys behind us.
So did you switch back at that point?
Switched back and I drove out.
He actually did not end up driving again,
that wasn't by design,
that was more related to
what ended up happening,
which we'll talk about next.
I was waiting for you
and I was like, why are they not here yet?
He gave me permission to tell that story.
And I was like, listen,
and, as we were driving out,
we actually had a good conversation,
I was like, listen,
man, this kind of thing,
this is why you do this,
so you can have a story.
Or so your dad can have a story,
you get a podcast one day,
you can have the story.
No, I was like, you've got
your first driving story.
And second.
Yeah, first and second.
I'd call that two stories.
Two for one,
and you're safe, no one got hurt,
we can have a laugh about it,
you learn something, you move on,
and we actually got to a good place.
You catch up with us, I hear the story
and then we ended up driving
all the way out of the valley
to Beatty to refuel,
and then we knew there
was a ghost town there
that we dropped in on, we ate some lunch,
then we came back into
the canyon, Titus Canyon,
which is one of the more popular drives,
but, again, that time of the year,
not that many people there, great drive.
The best drive.
Like, again, it's not technical,
it's best to have high clearance,
but no problem at all for the van.
We saw a guy in a Maxima.
We did.
And it's a one-way thing.
Do not recommend that.
It's got a lot of wash boarding.
But there was a Maxima there.
Your car is shaking as you go.
Also saw a guy on a bike
doing the whole thing,
that's nuts.
There is this, and this is
where I got drone footage,
I haven't looked at it,
it probably won't be that impressive.
But as you come down out of
the mountains and the canyon,
you're on one of those ice
road truckers sort of roads
in which, obviously, there's no guardrail
and there's just a sheer drop
into a canyon on one side,
and it's one lane wide
and that's exciting,
we had a good time.
And then at the end you
get into the slot canyon.
Amazing.
Where you're literally
driving in a canyon.
The width of the car.
Is the width of a road
with straight, stone walls.
The width of a single lane
of a road.
Yeah, right.
One way.
And it's not just straight.
Winding back and forth.
It winds back and forth,
so you can never see more
than 15 yards in front of you.
And that's why it's one way.
Yeah, that bottleneck.
Yeah.
So we go through that
and it was really cool to go with the boys
and to have these experiences.
For the first part of that trip,
Lando, actually, was asleep in the back,
I don't know how he did
it, it was so bumpy.
We were worried
and there was a couple of places
where Locke would be like, dad, dad,
you sure about this?
'Cause it freaks you out,
'cause you're like, well, if a rock falls.
If you reach down and
change the radio station,
if you got a radio station at that point,
then you could careen off
the side of the thing.
All systems are online
when you are doing this.
Absolutely.
And Lincoln was like, I
don't know how Lando's doing.
That's a good point,
well, he was sleeping.
He was sleeping.
That's the miracle of it all.
So I got Shep to sit in
the front seat with me
and I'm like, you like Steely Dan?
Shepherd's an old soul.
You've been training him
on what to listen to,
he didn't know them by name,
but we were listening to some Dan.
I really feel like we had
this kind of uncle moment,
it was cool for all of us to hang out
and, incidentally,
Lincoln told me about sleeping
over at the house with Locke,
subsequent to this trip.
Everything he told me that he did,
he was like, me and Locke
and Rhett, we ate this
and then me and Locke and
Rhett, we watched a movie,
I was like, it sounds
like you were hanging out
with Locke and Rhett the whole time,
I felt a little threatened,
I was like, you know what,
this is good uncle vibes.
We watched just a heinous horror movie.
He told me.
That trip really fostered
an extended family type of connection
and that's just the magic of camping,
is that you find yourself
around a campfire
and you can over glamorize it,
and, trust me, there's a lot of stuff
that, the majority of
time, is not glamorized,
but then you find those
moments that you can hold onto,
like the Steely Dan moment
when it's this amazing view,
you guys were way ahead of us
and then you had the drone
by the time we caught up.
And then you just stop
at this, a ghost town,
there was a place called Lead Field
which is just a place that sprung up
when they thought they
were gonna be mining lead
and it turns out
that the place had a
post office for 11 months
and 300 people lived there.
And they've got the pictures out there
of what it used to look like,
and there's still three buildings standing
that you can walk around.
The mines are closed off.
The mines are closed
but you can walk up to 'em and look in,
and they've got 'em
marked off.
Yeah, super cool.
And the kids were really into this
and us talking about what
would it have been like
to be out here 120 years ago, mining lead?
You know?
I mean, we come back and we're
telling all these stories
and Lily's like, I kind
of wish I would have gone
and I was like, girl,
you can go next time.
But it was cool for her
to say that out loud.
'Cause she was definitely not down.
Yeah, she wasn't interested
and her and Christy were hanging out,
and it was good for them.
So we leave Lead Field and, again,
you go through that slot
canyon at the end of that trip
and then you're like, man,
we're chasing daylight here,
we gotta find a place
to camp for the night.
And, again, we didn't wanna
be in the middle of the valley
where there are some
pockets of civilization,
like a gas station and a campground,
and one hotel with a bunch of palm trees,
which is so super strange.
I would say a resort.
Yeah, a resort, it's strange.
Super nice.
The only one they let in there to develop
or maybe the only people willing to do it
and to keep it up.
But, anyway, we actually drive past that
and you had found, on the map,
if we go up this canyon
called Echo Canyon,
we start going up that on
that high clearance road.
A lot of people camping there
and there was a truck in front
of us that was going so slow,
he let us go by,
and then I'm like, man,
we've been driving all day,
my shoulders are sore, I am exhausted,
I just feel like I can't
steer this thing anymore.
I'm feeling every bump in the road,
I'm glad we're almost
to finding a campsite.
And with every rock we hit and
every turn we tried to make,
I was like, man, if I didn't know better,
this feels like my first pickup truck,
a 1987 Nissan pickup,
had no power steering.
Yeah.
I was like,
that's what this feels like.
And then I was like, hold on,
I think that might be what happened.
The thing we haven't talked about.
And it's getting dark.
We were talking on our walkie talkies,
having a walkie talkie.
Oh yeah.
Being able to, hey, big boy, over.
Little boy, over.
Talking back and forth to each other,
that's the way to go on a
off-road trip like that.
There was lots of checking in
and also lots of walkie jokes.
Walkie jokes, yeah.
If you'll look to your left right now,
you'll see a big pair of
boobies, things like that.
It's just rocks.
Yeah, you gotta make those kinds of jokes
when the boys are around.
Just squint a little bit.
Yeah, right.
I say that 'cause you were on the walkie
and you were like, I'm
having trouble steering.
I'm tired.
I think there might be something wrong
with my power steering.
And, I'll be honest with
you, when you said that,
I was like, I just think he must be tired,
there's nothing wrong with that,
there's nothing wrong with
that brand new, super nice van.
It's getting harder by
the second to steer,
it's getting darker by the second.
We're having to pass
all these people camping
and then we.
Go up in a slot canyon.
We go in a slot canyon
and we found this super cool campsite.
Oh man.
And you hop out and I hop out,
and I'm like, man, I swear,
I've lost power steering,
I'm losing power steering.
And you look under the front
and something's leaking,
it's wet under there,
that's exactly what it is.
It's a scary feeling,
'cause we had gotten to the point
where we felt that isolation,
'cause that's where we like to camp.
And it was just, there's
this sinking feeling
of this could get bad
real quick, you know?
'Cause it's like, it'd be so
hard to get a vehicle in here,
like a tow truck in here
to get this thing out.
So I'm like, we can't camp here,
we gotta get this thing
back out of here right now.
If it's leaking power steering
before it's all bone dry,
which could potentially
do damage to the vehicle,
I gotta try to get this thing back out,
closer to civilization.
So we turn right back around
and go all the way back out,
and by the time we got back out,
I'm like, hanging a right
onto the paved road,
I'm trying with all of my
might to turn the wheel
to get this thing back.
'Cause this is not an
'87 Nissan pickup truck.
No, it's not.
This is a big vehicle.
We drove back down into the
valley, to a campground,
which said it was totally full.
Furnace Creek Campground,
'cause I wanna give a
shout out to the rangers,
the park rangers who were at the camp.
'Cause there were some Mythical Beasts.
There were Mythical Beasts, yeah.
But the night before,
we talked to the guy who
lives there permanently,
older guy who was like,
well, they didn't show up,
you can stay in this reserved slot.
Lyle.
Lyle, love you Lyle.
So we're like, you know what?
I can still camp in
this thing for tonight,
I called the owners or texted the owners,
I told 'em what was up.
They were understanding
and helped me problem solve
in terms of what we're
gonna do with this thing.
They said, well, since you're situated,
we'll have to find out the next morning
what the best course of action is
in calling the roadside assistance.
So that night was,
we were able to have an actual fire there,
not with the propane fire.
I went to the fancy general store,
which was at a little outdoor
mall resort kind of situation
in the middle of the desert,
to get this firewood that
costs me $13 a bundle
and I got three bundles,
that's some expensive wood.
We had a good night that night.
The next day we find out
that no, they can't come out and fix it,
this is such a new vehicle,
they're gonna have to come
tow it to the nearest place,
which is Las Vegas.
And can I say that we,
you talked about our non prowess
when it comes to diagnosing
vehicular problems,
but I say, between the two of us.
We were right about that.
We thought what had happened was
is that the hose to the pump
had completely come loose,
based on the spray pattern.
Oh, forensics.
Of the power steering fluid,
and it turns out,
that's exactly what had
happened to the car.
I'll fast forward,
so we arranged for the tow truck to come
and then the owner said
"We're just gonna get 'em
to tow it all the way
back to Los Angeles",
three and a half hours?
From there it was four and a half hours.
Four and a half hours.
And the tow truck came
from LA, picked it up,
and then went the four
and a half hours back.
And it couldn't be fixed
because the clamp is a proprietary clamp
that you found out very
soon after, that Mercedes.
People talk about it online.
Had issued a recall.
Well, that's what I
found out, weeks later.
So, just to close that loop,
yeah, whenever I was
returning stuff to the owner
that I'd taken out of the van,
she was like, I just got the notice today,
the recall for them to fix that.
So I know I didn't do
anything inappropriate,
but it made me feel better
that like, hey, this is a
Mercedes problem, not a.
A Link problem.
But that took most of our day
'cause we had to drive all the way out,
you had to drive me out to the
nearest place to rent a car,
all the way out of the valley
and rent a minivan,
bring it all the way in,
and so we kinda lost a day.
Significant downgrade
in how cool you seemed
the rest of the trip.
Yeah.
You went from having
a van that was so big.
#vanlife goes to #minivanlife,
totally different life.
The minivan life was not,
I didn't wanna be in pictures
with you and your minivan anymore.
I took a picture of the Sprinter
being loaded up on the ramp.
I got that on video, too.
Oh, cool, drone footage?
No drone, but I got that on video.
I wanna see that, that's cool.
Last story we gotta tell.
We had enough time.
Is we all hopped in the
minivan as the sun was setting
and we drove to this one canyon,
it was called Sunset Canyon
or something like that
and we knew it was gonna get dark,
that meant I grabbed a jacket,
but it didn't mean that
I grabbed flashlights
or headlamps, or anything,
'cause we did not do that.
Right, but, as it was
getting dark, it was clear
and me and Locke were, actually,
we kinda got up ahead of you guys
and we were walking ahead of everybody.
And, again, it was this crazy canyon
that's got this chalky white rock,
that's almost like dirt meets rock,
like dirt that hasn't yet become rock,
so, sedimentary rock that is
still very sedimenty, right.
And a lot of people are walking
out as we're walking in,
up into this, basically
another slot canyon.
But you could see that the
moon was gonna be bright
and, actually, as the sun was going down
and the moon was coming up,
you could already see your moon shadow.
Pretty crazy.
And I was like, oh, this is gonna be fine,
we don't need lights,
let's just keep going.
I will say, when it was all said and done,
I'm like, Lando, what
was your favorite thing?
He was like, the night hike.
'Cause, at a certain point,
we started calling this,
all right, guys, this is the
night hike, we're doing it,
you know.
And we went in a few miles,
you get up against this
sheer mountain faces
they call it the cathedral.
The Red Cathedral, yeah.
There's red rock wall.
And you and Locke had
gotten a lot farther ahead
and, matter of fact, I convinced myself
that you guys were gonna try
to scare the crap out of us
and I was not that happy about that.
But when we got to the cathedral.
You and Locke?
Yeah, so we got to the
end of the end of the line
and there was a cave
you had to walk through
to get to the final end of the trail.
And we could hear, this is so weird,
we could hear you guys
talking to each other.
Crisp?
Like I could make out the
words that you were saying.
And so I wanted to make sure
that you were gonna come all the way
and you weren't gonna turn around.
And so I was like, Link, I
yelled as loud as I could.
Didn't hear anything.
No response.
But you could hear me
just talking normally.
Some acoustic issue,
where I couldn't get my voice to go to you
and I think it might be
because you were in this little cave thing
and it was coming out of the cave,
but I couldn't get my
voice to go into the cave.
Rhett, no one will ever
know, it's a mystery.
It's an acoustic mystery.
That keeps me up.
That keeps you up at night,
you're thinking about it.
But then you finally show up.
And it's pretty cool
because, at this point,
you go into the sheer
wall of the cathedral
and then you double back
and go up this pyramid
of dirt to this ridge
that, then, we started
taking pictures of the kids.
I took a silhouette picture of the kids.
Backlit by the moonlight
and it was super cool.
And so I'm down below, you're
up a little bit ahead of me,
taking a picture of all
of the boys up there
on the ridge
and then we take the pictures
and we're like, all right,
let's start heading back down.
And just as we start heading back down,
there's some sort of a, there's
a little bit of a kerfuffle,
there's something going on,
there's some shimmying
happening and some grunting
as people are starting to come down.
And the first thing that I hear said,
I could tell people were concerned
and Lando says, please,
nobody say any bad words.
And so I'm like, okay, what has happened?
Well, apparently he had
picked up on a pattern,
which is if things went wrong,
there were bad words that were said.
Please nobody say any bad words.
That upset him.
I was like, what's happened?
It turns out what had
happened was Shepherd,
who let me just go on record and say
that Shepherd, actually,
has a great track record
with keeping up with his phone,
not so much with my other son,
but great track record of
keeping up with his phone
and not losing things.
But Shepherd had dropped
his relatively new phone
that had proceeded to
slide down this cliffside,
I mean, we're talking a 45 degree angle
that just kind of went down
into the lower part of the Red Cathedral.
Which was a dark abyss, really.
And we could not see anything.
And even when we shined our
phone lights onto the slope
we were like, there's no way
that we're gonna find this,
but it felt like the phone
has gotta be right there.
And so.
Did you say any bad words?
I didn't say any bad words,
'cause Lando said not to.
I don't think that's true.
No, I said one, what did I say?
I think after looking for about 15 minutes
and crab walking down
that 45 degree slope,
and kind of feeling like
you don't know what you could tumble into,
you kinda started getting
a little bit more grouchy.
Well, here's the thing.
And I'd walked down below,
'cause I was down at the bottom
and you were up at the top,
and the phone was somewhere in the middle.
As I was walking down this cliffside,
I was thinking to myself,
am I going to die trying
to find my kid's phone?
He's never gonna forgive himself,
is he gonna watch his dad
tumble off this cliff in the moonlight
and be like, ah, my dad's dead
because I dropped my phone.
So that's when I started to
joke with them about that.
Yeah, again, Lando.
Lando didn't like that.
Yeah.
'Cause I was like, all right Shepherd,
here I am, going to find your phone,
this might be the last time we talk.
You're twisted.
I'm a little twisted.
Scaring the crap out of children.
But I also felt like I wasn't gonna die.
Dismembering birds, who are you?
That was my brother,
and it wasn't like at the end of the cliff
it just dropped off to nothingness,
it was just the trail.
Right.
So I was like,
at worst, I'll just be badly injured.
Right, you're not gonna
fall into oblivion,
you're gonna fall to the
trail where I'm standing.
But, as you know, I'm scared of heights,
I was trying to overcome that
and not let anybody know.
But eventually, I was like,
I can't see this phone
and I'm afraid
that if I get to a place
where I can't get back up,
then we're gonna be
calling in the chopper,
assuming there is one.
And so, come back up, we
go around to the bottom
and we get down there,
and Shepherd, of course, is
already climbing up the cliff
to try to get his phone.
He might be addicted to screens,
that might be what was driving him.
He's way up there
and I'm a little worried about him,
and then I'm like, well,
I gotta go up there too.
So I went up there and
five minutes passed,
I ended up finding the phone,
I was able to spot it with
my light and we got it.
And we got out with only one,
maybe two curse words said,
and no injuries.
Yeah, Lando was cool with that,
that's the end of that story.
He still said, my favorite
thing was the night hike,
so you didn't ruin it for him.
Good.
Completely.
But yeah, that's the catch phrase now,
if anything wrong happens,
first thing you need to say is,
okay, please, nobody say any bad words.
I'm about to tell you something
you're not gonna wanna hear,
just don't say any bad words.
It ended up being an incredible trip.
I'm so glad, we're saying
that it was your idea,
I'm so glad you had that idea.
I wish we had had already done it more,
now that our kids are
the age that they are.
They'll wanna go next time.
Here's the thing.
That's the good news.
Is that before we went on that trip,
I think, in Locke's mind it was like,
I'm not gonna do this
again, but, by the end,
he was talking about how
good of a time he had had,
how much he liked being out in nature.
And then, on the way back,
I drove Locke and Lincoln,
and I let them be my DJ
and, boy, the musical
journey that we went on
that started in dad music
territory, John Mayer, et cetera,
slowly started getting into
some hip hop that I enjoy,
then began to transition into
maybe, some modern hip hop,
à la 21 Savage.
Talk about bad words.
We made up for all the bad
words that we had held back
in the presence of Lando,
we went well over the limit.
If you include what the
artists were saying.
If you include what the artist said
in the last hour of our trip.
My van did not have the
capability to connect to my phone
and most of the time.
Oh, I was about to say that
Mercedes, but I forgot,
no, you were in a Dodge.
I'm in a minivan
at this point,
it did not connect to my phone
and we hardly had any radio stations,
so the only thing I listened to
was how bad my kid's and
your kid's feet smell.
Yeah.
Like, we had to pull over,
Shepherd was wearing shoes with no socks.
And he'll take his shoes
off when he gets in the car,
can't let him do that.
I'm like, man,
we had to pull over so he
could go up to your car,
pull out that drawer,
and get some socks out.
It's like a biohazard.
We had a great trip,
it's our privilege to
have shared it with you
on this "Ear Biscuit", a great
way to kick off the year,
it's just a good thing to build on,
is that we can be outdoors.
I still don't know what
I wanna do about the van,
if there's a van in my future,
I think I'm just gonna
stay on the rental front
'cause this kind of
scared me a little bit,
something that drastic, that
required that much towing.
It was nice to rent it
and not be responsible.
I think the rental.
Is nice, yeah.
Is the way to go for one of those.
Yeah.
It's not that hard to load your stuff up.
That's what I'm leaning
towards at this point.
It was a good trip, man.
And next week we will talk about,
it seems like every time we go somewhere
or there's a break,
there's stories to tell,
so we're gonna talk about.
The holidays.
The holiday break.
Whatever came from that.
Next week.
I'm assuming that we'll talk about that,
but #EarBiscuits,
let us know if you wanna
weigh in on any of this.
Oh, and I got a recommendation.
First 'rec of 2021.
New year, new 'rec.
I've found this series on HBO Max,
forgive me if you don't have HBO Max,
but it's just another reason to get it.
"Calm" is one of the apps
that does meditations,
but they have a series,
you know about this series
on HBO?
No.
It's called "A World Of Calm"
and, let's see, there's
a number of episodes,
but, basically, it's reminiscent
of the calming nature
of watching primitive
technology on YouTube,
just watching somebody in a process.
They have a more meditative,
it's much more edited and
produced version of that,
it's the most calming
documentary that you could watch,
intentionally calming documentary.
I've only watched one episode.
Give me an example.
The episode I watched is called
"Living Among The Trees",
narrated by Keanu Reeves.
Oh.
And it is a guy who takes one felled tree
and turns it into a canoe,
so like a single tree, whole canoe.
And he doesn't talk,
there's no interviews,
it's just calming music
and footage of him, narrated by Keanu,
of him making a Kaneu.
How old, I mean, how long is this?
This episode, it's 23 minutes long,
so it's super cool to watch.
That's the only one I've watched,
there's one about snowfall,
"The Bird's Journey"
narrated by Nicole Kidman.
I mean, it sounds like I'm giving an ad,
but it's just a really cool idea.
HBO Max has been a sponsor.
Yeah, that's right.
"The Coral City" narrated
by Lucy Liu is episode one,
"Glassmaker" by Zoe Kravitz, narrated by,
"The Great Beyond" narrated by Idris Elba.
Now, this is a good idea.
Yeah, this is super cool.
Oo, "A Horse's Tale", like T-A-L-E.
Who does that one?
Kate Winslet.
Oh my.
"The Gift Of Chocolate".
Dang, so there's 10
episodes on this thing,
"World Of Calm", check it out.
It's nice to be able to watch something
that kind of feeds your
soul and gives you rest,
and doesn't just distract you,
but is a meditative experience.
I need to watch that
before I help my son drive.
There you go, man.
Or maybe after.
Or during.
All right, we'll speak at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.